[Musique]
mon cher petit à petit bourg prison
le premier est de faire de nouveaux
copains c'est la parisienne les caméras
de mon plein salut à vous savez moi en
plus de pas du coin me fallait un peu de
temps pour me faire accepter et encore
j'étais ni parisienne divorcer
[Applaudissements]
on va sans les bases va le remplacer par
un public surpris
[Applaudissements]
si branca l'on retrouve folie avant nous
valent livre aux bouchers qui vont
prendre la chair à pâté et du saucisson
il faut nous aider moi ça me tente pas
qu'ils sont échappés tamponnais mais
comment tu te rates tes animaux
et
le perçage co politicide d'accord ovi
juré craché tu peux partir tranquille
pour être occupé pour un moment
maman je vais enlever de la maison
et c'est moins fun moi je connais bien
le secteur de lundi on a touché d'état
qui valent tous je vous aime tellement
la douleur mais oui mais déjà la boîte
du coup tu peux vite la gamme
il me semble
c'est
ap
en salle
allah
la trappe les gens là